today we're talking about attack on
titan and call of duty's newest
crossover stalker 2 being delayed and
more
call of duty season 1 reloaded is set to
bring new dlc to vanguard and warzone
including a new submachine gun to unlock
and dlc from the iconic series attack on
titan this mid-season update is out now
for vanguard and warzone will get its
update on january 12th at 9pm pacific
attack on titan fans can purchase
cosmetic bundles to become a survey
corps member through the tracer pack
attack on titan levi edition bundle this
will be a 10 item store bundle which
includes the titan piercer weapon
blueprint that models the blade for
slaying titans while any operator can
use the weapon in finishing move the
levi's skin is exclusive for the
operator daniel also available in levi's
bundle is the legendary steel cut
finishing move as well as the vanguard
exclusive vertical maneuver highlight
intro and the ultra steel mvp highlight
the other two weapons in the levi bundle
are the legendary historia submachine
gun and the ymir curse assault rifle
weapon blueprints this collaboration
will officially become available on
january 20th approximately one week
after the mid-season update for vanguard
and warzone vanguard is also adding a
new operator to multiplayer and warzone
with the introduction of isabella who
will be the final operator on task force
006 trident to arrive before the end of
season 1. isabella is unlocked by
purchasing her wild rose operator bundle
which also includes two legendary weapon
blueprints the wall gun submachine gun
will become available to everyone to
unlock in season 1 reloaded like past
mid-season weapons the wall gun will be
available either through an unlocked
challenge for free or with purchase of a
store bundle
fans seem a little torn between being
excited for an attack on titan crossover
and confused about its association with
call of duty either way i know a lot of
us wanted to see a brand new mode but
the skins and other cosmetics will have
to do
stalker 2 heart of chernobyl has been in
development for a long time and it looks
like that process is going to be getting
longer as gst gameworld has announced
that the game will be delayed to
december of 2022 a statement on twitter
said that the additional 7 months are
needed to fulfill their vision and
achieve the desired state of the game
stalker 2 is the biggest project in gst
history and requires thorough testing
and polishing a delay is never an easy
decision but gsc world also mentioned
that more information updates and
showcases are coming and promised an
exciting and important year ahead this
delay comes shortly after gsc game world
courted controversy when the team
revealed it would be incorporating nfts
into stalker 2. but after backlash from
the community it was quickly announced
that all plans to incorporate nfts into
the title had been cancelled
hitman 3 year 2 is arriving on january
20th and developers io interactive have
announced that there will be big reveals
on january 13th we'll be seeing never
before seen footage of the second year
of post launch content for hitman 3
including elusive target arcade pc vr
the reveal of a brand new game mode and
more the stream will be a pre-recorded
15-minute video with developers from i o
interactive's copenhagen studio that is
said to be packed full of announcements
reveals and footage of new content
coming to the world of assassination in
2022
you can tune into the show at 6 a.m
pacific on the hitman youtube channel or
check back in for the full vod right
here on gamespot
however to circle back to attack on
titan and call of duty if this means
more of our favorite shows are going to
be coming to the fps world what's the
next crossover you want to see let me
know in the comments and be sure to
leave a like subscribe and come back
tomorrow for your next episode of
gamespot news
[Music]